Sal and Richard have put together
something they're gonna come in here
nude robbing toupper brace yourself Oh
God and they're going to how do you
describe this Gary what are they going
to be doing the guys so they're holding
a banner there's a banner that's going
to celebrate what's going on you guys
you're completely nude yes in honor of
you have the belt holding their mic pack
the belt holds their these guys love to
be me we've been naked 10,000 hours on
the show yeah we're experts however
there's a little room back there right
and we were all waiting back there right
till you call this in yeah I had to
leave the room smelled Richard smell his
[__] does break a little bit why as soon
as he dropped his pants everybody got a
little I love you you better get down
and smell it no we smell seriously does
it smell I didn't know we were going to
do this what happened your [__] isn't
clean most of the time at least to start
the day the last time you bathed your
[__] I think Sunday oh my god the two
days of fermentation is there yeah
because it's our job Gary this is not
really bad of it okay where are the
rooms the rooms like because it's more
room so it's a little warm and then it's
just like was the smell and and so the
guys will tell you I was not [__]
around right I was in there for 45
seconds then I go I apologize guys
smells in this room and I went waited
out front and Sal you it's not you know
it's not men right I mean Gary get away
from my [__] and let me know if it
stinks yeah come on Gary you have to say
who it is I swear I won't do a thing I
will find you I'll do it Richard I'm
Richard don't
don't move Richard what does it smell
like okay it's like it's like you know
when you like to own a cabin and you
haven't opened up the windows for the
whole song
[Laughter]
how is this honoring my book going in um
a roll of wrapping paper and that's
what's holding the banner up so each of
the guys you can put their dick in the
hole we're docking this is called
docking all right there we go
did they go then I will pull the string
here you really think that's gonna hold
what they're doing is their dicks are
holding up a banner that celebrates this
is being number one their dicks are like
the toilet paper holder that's right the
addiction like the toilet paper holder
and the toilet paper will be me and the
pictures game number one on thank you
guys I moved Thank You Howard
congratulations thank you don't move
guys say cheese dick cheese there you go